hey everyone what's up welcome back to
css3 in 30 days also known as code 30
things in 30 days at css3 for the last
few days you've been coding some really
cool things in css3 building actual
practical things and widgets and buttons
and clip paths and all these fun little
things and we're gonna be adding more
and more as we go over the following
there are over the next 30 days and so
the purpose of doing this is to help you
just build things just jump in and
sometimes going over your head figure
out survive and just make it happen make
it work and the cool thing is that I'm
here to help you the people in the
course are here to help you and the
final CSS files are here to help you so
you can reference what's going on why
did that do that and and that's the
purpose of this to push you to help you
build things so that you can actually
learn how to make things in CSS and css3
so today in day four we're gonna be
building and styling up a sexy
registration form so jump on over here
into my browser and we're gonna use CSS
CSS to style the following webform right
here into something visually attractive
with a great user experience and of
course refer to the final result for
some help so this thing doesn't look so
nice you know it's it's a form it's not
functional but in theory it's functional
let's say it created an account you know
you'd enter your name and your email and
then or your your emailing your password
and your create your account you know
it's a form it's HTML it works in theory
but it doesn't look good it doesn't have
a good user experience or a good user
interface so if I scroll down this final
result it's much more attractive it's
got a nice background a cool gradient in
the back to pop the the login create an
account widget pops up off the
background you can enter you know it
gives you instructions it's very clear
the conventions of this form look very
much like what people are used to you
know it's very nice and appealing you
know you click on an input and it fades
in a little bit it's just it focuses it
looks nice the button is cool you go to
click on it and it kind of has this
really neat like kind of a striped
effect that grows in the background and
then even when you hover over this
widget itself it almost like shuffles
down paper like cards almost like
rolling a deck of cards so it just all
around has a neat user experience and
user interface so we're gonna be doing
that in CSS and css3 over in our code
editor I've got a for a folder called
sexy registration form it's number four
in this module there is a link to
download number four sexy registration
forms open that up in your code editor
of course we have the index with all the
markup that you are more than welcome to
reference sandbox ah CSS where we are
going to be coding our styles and final
the CSS that you can use for reference
to see how the final result is built so
if you have any problems or mistakes
then you can you can go there refer to
that and fix up those issues so inner
sandbox at CSS let's get started now
before we write a lick of CSS let's go
to our HTML I know I'm jumping you all
over the place here but hang with me and
let's see the markup the markup super
simple we have a div with the class of a
register wrapper within that we have a
div called register block and then in
there we have a level three heading
paragraph and then the form itself with
three inputs within it an email password
and a submit button so very very simple
markup just at four eight nine ten
eleven you know like ten or eleven lines
of CSS very very simple markup then our
sandbox is where all the magic is gonna
happen in our CSS so let's start off by
selecting the register - wrapper and in
there we're gonna do the background
image and we're gonna give it a WebKit
linear gradient and it's gonna be at 135
degrees the color we're gonna start with
0 ee FF 0 at a 30% color stop and then
the next color so comma separates 0 8 8
F 90 at a 90 percent color stop so those
two colors the first color value and the
second color value it starts at 30% and
then 90 percent so that gradient we'll
use those as
to give transitions to create an
interesting gradient that happens in
those specific color stops so what I'm
gonna do there is I'm gonna copy that
and make sure we semicolon paste it and
instead of WebKit linear your gradient
for the second we're gonna just use
linear gradient same values don't worry
about changing anything there semicolon
and we're going to say position relative
and then the set index will be three
padding let's give it 100 pixels on all
sides the font size I don't think we
need to play around with font side size
actually color is gonna be triple nine
the color of the text within is when you
triple nine now save that let's see what
we got here in our there we go so check
this out we have 135 degree angle it's
going down kind of up from top left to
the bottom right
slightly off it's more so going from
like here to here I believe you know so
whatever 135 degrees is and change the
value to see what what happens and then
that the we got the gradient at the 30%
color stop around here and then the 90
percent colors stop here so you can see
how they you know if you were to change
those colors up values or add more you
would see how the gradient changed or if
you added more colors with different
color stops feel free to play with that
just to become familiar the color is
triple 900 pixels and padding looks good
let's go back to our code editor and get
back into it's a register wrapper and
then the asterisk which is basically a
catch-all it selects every element
within the register wrapper dip and
we're just gonna say box sizing is going
to be border box basically the reason
why we want to do that is to so that the
padding doesn't add any value of any of
the elements within there when we add
padding we don't want it to add any
width to the container we wanted to stay
within the border box rather than when
we add 30 pixels on either side of a
hundred pixel box we don't want it to be
160 pixels now because it's added some
weight some size we want it to stay
within there and just work with this the
fixed width so that's the border box
property box sizing property rather and
then now let's go below that we're gonna
say register wrapper form
and then input so we're selecting all
the inputs there's three of them
display:inline-block the width will be
100% the padding we're gonna go zero on
top and bottom twenty pixels left and
right the line height there's going to
be fifty pixels the height will be 50
pixels so this will Center the
vertically Center the text
the background color is going to be
white the border will be solid one pixel
be 60-66 the border bottom width will be
three pixels so we'll have a larger
bottom border the border radius we're
gonna give it something subtle like five
pixels and we're gonna do
WebKit transition all zero point three
seconds and ease we've been using that a
lot and then copy that paste it and just
make it transition all three point three
seconds ease save that head back to the
browser check it out so we have this
100% weight like big nice inputs when
you click on it it fades some things in
there with the transition it fades in
the border but that outline kind of
messes up the effect a little bit so
let's head back and we're going to just
probably under here say outline:none
save that head back over here and now
that should have taken care of that
outline very nice okay so now what we're
gonna do is head back to our code editor
and we're going to select register a
wrapper form input and then colon and
it's gonna match not so it matches an
element that is not represented by the
arguments so what are we not selecting
here this is a cool CSS trick here so
form input not another colon last child
so a virtual element here so matches any
element that is the last child of its
parent basically we want to select the
inputs that are not the last child don't
select the last element the last input
element within the form which is the
submit button so that's just an
interesting CSS selector css3 selector
way of just saying don't select the
input we could have just given an ID and
just said don't select that or something
but this is just a little bit more of a
fun way of doing it it's a bit more
dynamic margin-bottom
for the two inputs are gonna be 20
pixels
save that and I head over to your
browser you can see that it affected
only these two and not this one there's
no margin bottom for the create my
account button
cool now I head back to the code editor
we're gonna select the register wrapper
again the form input and then in square
braces we're gonna select the type
attribute and email and then focus
separate by comma copy that paste it out
three more times change the attribute
the type attribute to email and then
active as the state and then the third
value here we go sorry password and
that's gonna be focus and then password
active remove that last comma curly
braces border color
let's do triple C save that check it out
in the browser when we focus we get this
Triple C darker kind of gray border and
active so you can see that that covers
basically when you click on it it
changes the border color and gives it
just a little bit nicer of a focus which
takes care of the fact that we removed
the outline created our own outline
essentially now let's select the
register wrapper again form input but
we're just I'm I'm going to select the
type and the value the attribute will be
submit so we want to select that submit
button and change the style up for that
one so let's go ahead and say
position:relative
we're gonna go zetas next one
display:inline-block padding:0 and
twenty zero and top and bottom twenty
left and right pixels of course let's go
background color just the background is
going to be actually do background color
because we're gonna be selecting
background image later we're gonna go F
two three nine five a background size
100 percent and then we're gonna play
around with something cooler background
image we're going to do the WebKit
linear gradient and give a little space
there because we're going to do
something interesting we're gonna create
stripes
now normally what you would do to create
stripes you don't have to know the stuff
off by heart as you just go to like a
linear gracias history linear gradient
generator online you Google that and
then you just play around with it and
you could do different code snippets and
paste it in and you're off to the races
no need to invent reinvent the wheel but
here we're gonna manually code this out
so you can create the striped effect
which looks like this over here in the
browser so this striped effect so the
first value is going to be the degree in
which we want the avout the stripes to
go so 45 degrees first value is RGB a
we're gonna use that because we want to
say 255 255 255 0.15 which is like 15%
and then 25 % colors stop now if I left
it at that
all you're gonna get is just one single
color if we won't see any change there
now if I go back to my code editor and
add another value say rgba 0 0 0 and
then 0 basically that's like black but
you can't see it so it's creating just
like kind of an empty chunk at 25% color
stop save that you'll see what's gonna
happen so go over here you're going to
see now we actually have a bit of a
stripe there it's kind of created at the
25% color stop on the 45-degree angle a
bit of something something's going on
there now if we change this to like I
don't know like 0.8 go over here to your
browser you can see that this part is
actually the black part it's at 25% 25%
color stop at the 45-degree angle you
could see the black but because we
wanted at 0 we don't really want to see
it it's going to create this effect
right there alright so let's just keep
moving we're gonna do another line here
RGB a we're going to do 0 0 0 0 again at
the 50% color stop save that and you're
not gonna see any change there yet until
we get to the next value so go down to
the next line RGB a 255 255 255 , 0.15
this is white at 15 percent 50% color
stop save that head back over to the
browser now we got a stripe going on so
you can see that at the 50% mark we're
starting to make some stripes so carry
on carry on back in the browser or the
code editor here RGBA
we're gonna go to two five two two five
do we divide this is 0.15 again at the
75% color stop and let's continue to the
next line we're gonna say rgba we're
gonna do that space again with two zero
zero zero zero a black at the 75% color
stop and then last but not least we're
gonna do one more rgba 0 0 whoops zero
zero zero zero at just we're gonna leave
it that's just the end save that so if
we head over here we could see in our
browser it's just pink so something went
wrong let's go to our code editor I can
see it here I put a comma you might have
caught that instead of a decimal just
typing too fast not thinking save that
head back to the browser put that
obviously put that as a decimal head
over here you can see the stripes now
but they're a little bit large and
that's because of the background size so
head back here in the code editor we can
change that right here in background
size we could do something like 20
pixels and then 20 pixels so two values
so 20 pixels on the X&Y
head over here to the browser you can
see we've got got our stripes that looks
cool
so now let's continue we're gonna say
border:solid 1px OL we're gonna go F 0
to 1 4 6 and then we're gonna do border
border bottom width we're gonna do 3
pixels again we're gonna say the color
is white the outline is none we don't
want any outline on there as well
cursor and pointer sometimes you need to
add that for input that our inputs that
our buttons and then WebKit's transition
all 0.3 seconds 'yes copy that paste it
out change it to just transition save it
head back over here to the browser we've
got a nice neat button that looks nice
and consistent beautiful head back to
our code editor here now let's play
around with the effect when you hover
over this button so we're gonna say I'm
gonna tab this and I'm gonna say
register wrapper form input submit so
we're clicking that get enough on again
but the hover the hover State
we're just change the background size to
40 pixels 40 pixels so we're going to
increase that background size so head
over here to the browser hover over that
button it just
you get that effect so it creates the it
transitions the background size to
double the size of what it was before
you could change it to something really
big if you want like a tea and a tea and
see what happens so pretty intense a
little bit too much - you know I like
subtlety so 40 and 40 works for me and
now we're going
go to the next line and we're going to
say register title so we're just gonna
tight tidy up a few of these things here
register title font size let's do like
two Ram and then padding of bottom 20
pixels margin:0 0 20 pixels border
bottom we're gonna do dashed one pixel
be 60-66 save that let's check it out
what it looks like nice you know
nothing crazy it'll look better once we
have a background on their whole wrapper
there which we'll do here so let's go to
them the next line we're gonna say
register block and now we're going to
style that up we're gonna go
position:relative we're gonna say
display block width is 100% max width is
300 pixels so that's like so it can be
responsive up to a maximum of 30
that's where 300 pixels margin we're
gonna just say 0 auto because I don't
think we have any yeah 0 Auto so it'll
Center it padding will be 30 pixels
background will do white box shadow
let's have some box shadow 0 0 and 50
pixels and RGB a there we go zero zero
zero zero point two so it'll be like
every subtle black box shadow and then
border radius 5 pixels save it let's
check out what the register block looks
like check it out looks nice already
looks nice and subtle I like it I like
it
however when I'm looking here the font
size is a little bit too big all around
so let's go up to the top of our CSS
here and we're going to go register
wrapper and change the font size I'm
gonna change the font size let's do one
Ram and see what that does does it make
it smaller it does make it smaller over
here in the browser except for the
headline is a little bit large which is
down here in our code editor we did that
in a register title - Ram let's make
that 1.2 Ram 1.2 to small maybe 1.6 Ram
there we go that looks much better here
in the browser okay back to what we were
doing in the first place so we did the
register block now what we want to do is
create that a cool effect check it this
out when we hover over it will get that
kind of like shuffling card effect let's
go to our sandbox again and we're going
to create that so the register block I'm
going to tab this in because it's
related register block that before
pseudo-element and comma the register
block after pseudo elements we're going
to style both those up position:absolute
zet index negative one because it's
going to be behind the parent container
zero top left right and bottom are all
going to be zero and now we're going to
say display block width 100% height 100%
so it matches the original element the
register block elements height and width
content needs to be an empty string so
that so these pseudo elements will
actually appear if you don't have that
then it would they won't show up that's
something that a lot of web developers
beginner web designers developers forget
background we're gonna say white
border:solid 1px ol e 666 okay and then
we're gonna do border radius we're gonna
match what was where we're gonna match
the rest of it at five pixels now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna scale them
so if I save this and check it out you
won't really see anything nothing's
gonna be there so we're gonna scale
these and then we're going to create a
hover effect that makes them appear so
we're gonna say WebKit transform
scale 0.9 it's a little bit smaller
translate zero and zero copy that paste
it out we're going to change that to
just transform
beauty and then transition is gonna be
all 0.3 seconds ease all right so that
one is done you're not gonna see that at
all yet until we create this next effect
which is gonna be register and block
it's gonna be hover so when we hover
over the register block we're gonna
style the before pseudo-element
I say WebKit transform scale so I'm just
gonna paste what we had there scale but
we're gonna change it to something
slightly larger 0.96 so it's not the
same size as that as the original
register block and the translate this is
the x and y offset 16 pixels down on the
y axis
this one's just gonna be transform
and copy this out right below register
block hover and after we're going to
make this one even just a little bit
smaller than the than the before
pseudo-element
and this one's gonna be 32 pixels down
now I'm gonna save this but I'm gonna
comment this out first and show you what
that first one does so save that check
this out in the browser hover and that
first that before pseudo-element pops
down and that's pretty cool so now what
we're going to do is head back here
uncomment what we just coated up save
that and let's see what happens so watch
this do you see how the after pseudo
element is appearing in front of the
before soo element that's because it is
after cascade in the cascading style
sheet and it's going to appear in front
so that's why we use Zed index so that's
what we're gonna go here for the before
we're gonna say Zed index is gonna be
negative 1 because that's what it
originally is and for the after
pseudo-element we want this one to be
Zed index negative 2 so it's actually
behind the before pseudo-element back to
the browser hover there it is just like
that now if you wanted to do another
really cool effect here let's try
something I want to do this
YZ so that I'm gonna try and make it so
that they both don't come down at the
same time I want to make the after
pseudo element come down just a little
bit later so let's see if we can try
that we're gonna say you see here we
have before and after have the same
transition let's just add one more line
here and say register block after and
we're gonna make it have a different
transition time all you can even do
something like transition delay yeah
let's do to delight wanted to delay by
oh very very subtle like point two
seconds that might be well let's just
see what happens
okay check this out here in the browser
with the point two second delay watch
what happens
it's kind of a little bit weird so let's
make that delay really small like maybe
even 0.05 seconds and now let's check it
out
see how it has kind of like it's like
it's chasing
I like that cool work for me so that's
just a cool little effect and so there
we go there we have our sexy
registration form that we built in CSS
and css3 using a bunch just CSS css3 no
images no Photoshop none of that I hope
you enjoyed this lesson it was a little
bit long thanks for hanging with me
they're building a cool sexy
registration form I'll see you tomorrow
in day 5 of css3 and 30 days